that's the twist he's gonna get to
whatever the mission is he's gonna you
know like uncover yes that he is a toy
and that you know he is just one in a
long line of manufactured suits what if
this is tim allen's purgatory
just
[Music]
buzz lightyear to the rescue
[Music]
that's all i know full disclosure i've
never actually seen any of the toy story
movies so this is all gonna be brand new
for both john and i yeah i really feel
bad we probably should have say that for
after the reaction i mean a lot of
people are gonna click off because you
know the toy story fandom is rabid and
they don't suffer fools lightly
ah boy guys we got a trailer here for
light year i've heard a lot about this
it's gonna explore the evil emperor zerg
from my understanding right sworn enemy
of the galactic alliance yeah we
wikipedia that we really
don't know much about toy story no
woody's in this right woody's supposed
to return in this which is funny because
i thought he died in toy story 4. yeah
but but they'll resurrect him you know
and after that squid game video we put
out i also realized a lot of people know
how to pick up on sarcasm very well what
so guys let's get into this we're gonna
watch the lightyear trailer
is
[Music]
i could really feel the wonder yeah
wow
that perspective man
what the hell dang
when i heard it was a real life
astronaut i was like
oh i didn't realize it was like the
future
yeah
cowboy bebop
wow
yeah look at a wally robot
whoa
oh how neat
this is
awesome awesome
[Music]
age of ultron when you thought he was
going to finally say a badger's assembly
oh that's right that's where i was going
with this i haven't seen age of ultron
uh yeah
sarcasm i know yeah it's let's talk
about
i was pleasantly surprised by that when
i heard that okay this is gonna be
obviously we've seen toy story when i
heard that this was gonna be about i
thought it was like pictures real life
astronaut and like obviously not a real
life astronaut but in the world
i was like oh is this going to be a
1960s yeah yeah story because we have
andy who's playing with his toys
so i assumed that it was gonna be yeah
something like from wave and maybe it
still is but they are the the there was
like secret space adventures that the
government was really doing like i don't
know the full details of it when he was
like shooting past the sun and all that
and all these like aliens and such i was
pleasantly surprised by that oh well
this is actually way different than what
i thought it was gonna be because all i
heard all i heard was that one little
description of what the movie was gonna
be about it feels uh refreshing it feels
very classic pixar in the sense of all
the wonder that it's providing and it
looks beautiful to behold as usual i
like being enveloped in the pixar world
as much as anybody else i think chris
evans is a perfect choice
for
a classic american astronaut yeah i was
very much endeared to the tone that this
trailer struck and i'm sure it's going
to be even funnier than what we're
actually getting here but it's just
funny when you watch a pixar trailer and
you know that tears are on the way
that's what's really to infinity and
beyond are my tears drifting in the the
stratosphere
stratus tears
tears while i face my fears
hanging out with my friends at the bar
cheers
buzz light years yes
this is the venom buzz lightyear you
should call them up yeah i was really
enthralled by this too i went in with
like a margin of cynicism just because
you know there's been like a bunch of
toy stories and then we have already had
like buzz lightyear of star command the
show all the toy stories suck yeah and
all of them just got pretty aggressively
worse like dang i don't know for some
reason i was like i don't know you know
the buzz lightyear and this take but
yeah this really swept me up and the
idea that like i don't know how this
would fit into the toy story world
because it certainly looks like it's in
a legitimate future even so i'm not
really concerned about canon this just
looks like a really fun space adventure
and off the top i was getting these you
know kind of brad bird vibes and i like
that you know going into this story it
does seem to have the fun and adventure
and you know some of the humor that you
would expect from something coming out
of toy story but i like that they didn't
lead with that they led with the sense
of adventure a little bit of danger but
not so much that it seems like oh man
there's gonna be harrowing because you
know like space adventures can get that
way but this looked like a nice blend of
both like it would be very rollicking
and swashbuckling and wondrous but also
really warm and fun and endearing in all
the ways that you would hope toy story
adjacent could be well it's pixar so
you're not going to feel perilous at the
same time absolutely i think that's one
thing they they tend to get a good leg
up on when they're emitting all this fun
you're still like wow this is this is
kind of intense
totally and i like the idea of seeing
that in you know a more sci-fi realm
because we've had like wall-e which is
very much future sci-fi but while that
movie has action it's not as much about
you know like exploring the frontiers
it's more kind of a melancholy at the
end of all that there is to explore so
this seems like it could have you know a
unique flavor within the pixar canon
jumping into something that is more
action adventure sci-fi that i imagine
is quite marketable compared to various
other films that are popular these days
but that also could be that
gateway for younger people to get into
those kinds of movies like this for some
reason felt very earnest and very sort
of just committed to what it's doing and
not really concerned with like we gotta
make references to stuff i guess that
maybe was the source of my cynicism at
first is like you know there's always a
lot of pressure to tie things in whereas
this is like you got buzz and here's
this new world of star command that
we're gonna get to know well we also got
the suit we got the suit we got the suit
we got the reference to infinity neon so
it's not like it's void of references we
gotta know how the toy was manufactured
and what the dna is that when you turn
over that box and you read what's going
on here oh my god that's history he's
gonna get to the whatever the mission is
he's gonna you know like uncover yes
that he is a toy
and that you know he is just one in a
long line of manufactured suits what if
this is tim allen's purgatory
just lips
and is forced to listen as chris evans
does his voice or you find out that
after the story is told that it's woody
as he's hanging out at the carnival oh
says he's relaying the story of the
great
legendary buzz lightyear i think it's
really cool like with the animation that
they're struck here because hey you said
brad bird the animation still feels a
little bit more along the lines of in
terms of the the humanoid features i
would say closer to seoul or coco for
that matter but in the chris evans
portrayal of lightyear how he he does
look like the toy
yeah
the way they made those toys look is so
good yeah because he's got a little bit
of a chubby face here
yeah
well yeah it's funny because he looks
more like a real guy but still like the
toy like it is a bit of a redesign you
can tell but it's not uncanny no
yeah yeah i thought it was interesting
how they didn't really let chris evans
speak here though in the trailer which i
thought we would get more of but i felt
like that might have raised a little bit
more questions so i think on a marketing
standpoint it's actually pretty smart to
do it this way because it's getting you
more enthralled with the world and its
new mood and tone and the new things
that it's doing instead of having you be
distracted and going where's my home
improvement act right now
one that also builds anticipation for
his ultimate performance you know people
wanting to hear more than just the and
it's a tim allen impression it's
it was embarrassingly so and so they're
like we gotta hide this to the movie
they only got him only because tim allen
couldn't do it
yeah this looks surprisingly epic i'm
looking forward to this very much so
cool sci-fi adventure i wonder what the
bigger themes will ultimately be that
was the other thing too is it seemed
like this would even though it's not
really hinted at in the trailer i'm like
this seems like it will deal with like
the nature of exploration and you know
why buzz is doing this and yeah i can
imagine i might cry at the end i imagine
that'll probably hearken a little bit
back towards uh the original astronauts
the russian ones yeah the ones who
did everything we could defeat
comrade lightyear over here anyway guys
so what'd you think of the
let's just call lightning what did you
think of the light your trailer leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
bells hit like buttons talk to god
who is in space waiting for you